vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir des sanctions
progressives contre la jungle guinéenne
bilan de la réunion extraordinaire de la
CEDEAO qui s'est tenu à New York ce
jeudi soir comment réagit-on en Guinée
nous irons sur place dans ce journal
et au menu de cette réunion
extraordinaire de la CEDEAO il était
aussi question d'une partie du dossier
malien avec les 46 soldats ivoiriens
toujours détenus par Bamako nous irons
sur place en Côte d'Ivoire et nous
parlerons de toutes ces questions avec
CESI Kaba journaliste spécialiste du
Sahel avec
et nous vous parlerons d'avubakar
Soumaoro c'est un ancien ramasseur de
tomates dans le sud de l'Italie devenu
représentant syndical aujourd'hui c'est
italio ivoirien et candidat de gauche et
se présente comme le porte-parole des
exclus dans un pays où l'extrême droite
est au porte du pouvoir reportage à
suivre
on ouvre ce journal par le bilan de la
réunion extraordinaire de la CEDEAO qui
s'est tenue à New York ce jeudi soir en
marge de la de l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU et les dirigeants ouest africains
ont décidé d'imposer les sanctions
progressives sur les individus et contre
la gente muette guinéenne Caroline
Lamboley
cellule timatum prononcée vendredi par
la Cedeao les autorités guinéennes ont
un mois pour revoir à la baisse la durée
de leur transition jugée inacceptable la
CEDEAO a aussi détaillé le contenu des
sanctions annoncées la veille certains
membres de la jante seront interdits de
voyage et leurs avoir seront gelés
la CEDEAO suspendra tout assistance et
transactions financières en faveur de la
Guinée par ses institutions financières
enfin les États membres de la CEDEAO
vont également rappeler leurs
ambassadeurs accrédités en Guinée
arrivé au pouvoir par la force en
septembre 2021 la jante militaire
guinéenne a annoncé en avril une période
transitoire de trois ans avant de céder
la place à un gouvernement civil sur
notre antenne quelques heures avant le
sommet de jeudi le président en exercice
de la CEDEAO jugé ce calendrier
inacceptable
on ne peut pas dépasser les 24 mois ça
c'est les négociable pour la CEDEAO
des propos qui avant même l'annonce des
sanctions avait provoqué l'IR de la
gente militaire guinéenne et le propos
qui s'apparente à de l'intimidation sont
de nos jours des pratiques rétrogrades
qui ne dort pas son auteur et ternistes
par la même occasion l'image de marque
de la Cedeo
avait suspendu la Guinée au lendemain du
coup militaire de septembre 2021
et alors pour commenter cette actualité
on a avec nous cedikaba c'est l'un des
plus phases analystes de la situation
géopolitique du Sahel saidique merci
d'être avec nous dans le journal de
l'Afrique alors dites-nous comment
analyser vous ces sanctions de
progressive sur la jambe car d'un côté
les autorités guinéennes on a reçu le
porte-parole du gouvernement ici même
hier soir qui disait que il y avait des
discussions qui étaient je reprends le
terme bon enfant qui se passait bien
entre la CEDEAO et la junte et qu'il
comprenait pas finalement
la soudaineté ou la brutalité de ses
sanctions qui ont été décidées hier soir
à New York non
les décisions qui ont été prises par la
Cedeao l'ont été sur la base d'un
rapport qui a été fait par l'ancien
président du Bénin qui est l'envoi ce
qui est le médiateur désigné par la
Cedeao il y a eubonie le président Yayi
Boni qui a estimé que il n'y a pas de
progrès substantiel dans la mise en
oeuvre de la transition et il indique à
juste raison d'ailleurs qu'il n'y a à ce
jour aucun chronogramme et il faut
rappeler que une année s'est écoulée
depuis le renversement du président
Alpha Condé le 5 septembre 2021 et à ce
jour il n'y a pas de programme il n'y a
pas de chronogramme et il n'y a pas une
gestion inclusive de la transition les
partis politiques sont de côté la
société civile et de côté donc sur la
base des éléments qui ont été fournis
par les médiateurs de la CEDEAO la
décision a été prise de sanctionner et
la Guinée des sanctions immédiates et un
ultimatum a été donné à la Guinée si
d'ici au 22 octobre il n'y a pas un
nouveau chronogramme et il n'y a pas
d'avancée significative d'autres
sanctions supplémentaires vont être
prises alors on va écouter la réaction
en Guinée de la société civile justement
qui appelle les militaires au pouvoir à
plus de responsabilité pour éviter
sanctions qui pourraient selon elle
alourdir les souffrances du peuple
guinéen on écoute abdol sarkro il est
coordonnateur du Forum des forces
sociales en Guinée et on en parle juste
après nous allons vers l'accumulation et
des difficultés des souffrances pour la
population c'est pour cela il faut faire
à tout prix pour éviter au-delà de ses
premières sanctions prévues qu'on
n'aille pas dans une direction de
sanction qui va impacter la vie des
populations aujourd'hui et en déphasage
totale avec la majorité écrasante des
forces vives de la nation donc il va
être entre deux feux le feu au niveau
international et le fait au niveau
national
alors une question sur les sanctions
nous avons pas encore le détail de ces
sanctions on parle de sanctions ciblées
sur la jungle mais est-ce que ça peut
avoir un effet un impact ah oui
considérablement comme il a été si bien
dit aujourd'hui le contexte
international marqué par une inflation
importante dans tous les pays y compris
la Guinée et la situation intérieure de
la Guinée avec les conséquences de la
crise sanitaire qui n'ont pas encore été
soldées et les relations difficiles avec
ses voisins aujourd'hui si on met un
terme aux transactions financières et à
l'assistance financière à la Guinée qui
a des relations économiques étroites
avec le Sénégal par exemple avec ses
voisins comme la Côte d'Ivoire c'est
clair que ça va avoir un impact
considérable sur le guinéens ordinaires
peut-être que les gens de la jointe
auront les moyens encore de continuer à
avoir le même standing mais les Guinéens
ordinaires la ménagère guinéenne le
paysan guinéen va subir les conséquences
distinction que l'acideo prendra
incontestablement mais alors du coup des
sanctions ciblées sur la jungle ça peut
avoir un effet dissuasif oui il faut il
faut que la jointe comprenne puisque
déjà il y a un front intérieur ces
relations avec les partis politiques
sont exécrables ces relations avec la
société civile sans mauvaise si la jeune
décide de d'aller vers un affrontement
avec la Cedeo ce qui risque d'avoir un
soulèvement intérieur et je ne pense pas
que la jointe est besoin d'une
contestation interne encore plus grande
parce que elle pourrait être
déstabilisée et ça mettrait à mal même
son intention de rester au pouvoir
au-delà des 24 mois qui ont été
prescrits par la Cedeao absolument
aborder lors de ce sommet extraordinaire
de la CEDEAO c'est le sort des 46
soldats ivoiriens inculpés au Mali
depuis deux mois Bamako soutenant qu'ils
sont des espions que les autorités
ivoiriennes démontent fermement la Côte
d'Ivoire soutenue par la Cedeao qu'elle
tiendra pour responsable le Mali si
quelque chose arrivait au soldats les
précisions de notre correspondante à
Abidjan ça dire bonjour
c'est avec le soutien de tous les
présidents de la CEDEAO que le président
Alassane Ouattara est rentré de New York
alors que la crise entre le Mali et la
Côte d'Ivoire se poursuit l'instance
ouest africaine va envoyer à Bamako une
délégation composée des présidents
sénégalais togolais et ghanéens le but
bien sûr est d'obtenir la libération des
46 soldats je rappelle que ces soldats
sont inculpés depuis plus de deux mois
maintenant et sont accusés d'être des
mercenaires une source proche de la
présidence nous confiait tout à l'heure
que si jusqu'à aujourd'hui la Côte
d'Ivoire adoptait un comportement
fraternel elle pourrait perdre patience
et il ne faudrait surtout pas que la
situation s'éternise la Côte d'Ivoire
attend donc un dénouement très
prochainement mais si ce n'est pas le
cas elle pourrait prendre des sanctions
cette même source nous indiquait que le
Mali pays frères dépend économiquement
de la Côte d'Ivoire sur plusieurs points
notamment l'accès à l'électricité une
manière donc de dire que si la CEDEAO
n'a pas pris de sanction la Côte
d'Ivoire elle a les moyens d'en prendre
alors on poursuit ce sujet évidemment
sur le sommet extraordinaire de la
CEDEAO on a vu c'est du cabas tout à
l'heure donc là c'est la question des 46
soldats mais peut-être une question
peut-être technique expliquer pourquoi
il y a pas eu de sanction contre la
gente malienne comme il y en a eu contre
la la jointe guinéenne dans cette
réunion particulière absolument parce
que le point les deux points alors du
jour sont la Guinée et la situation des
soldats et il n'y a pas il ne s'est pas
agi d'une évaluation de la transition
malienne en tant que telle et c'est pour
cette raison d'ailleurs que l'ancien
président du Nigeria goundogue Jonathan
qui lui reste que le médiateur de du
Mali n'était pas à la réunion de New
York il y avait par contre son homologue
de la Guinée en charge de la Guinée le
président Yayi Boni comme on l'a dit
donc c'est le dossier de 46 soldats
ivoiriens qui a été examiné et là la
CEDEAO a épousé point pour point la
position de la Côte d'Ivoire la CEDEAO
comme d'ailleurs les Nations Unies ont
reconnu qu'il ne s'agit pas de
mercenaire il s'agit des soldats même si
des erreurs ont été commises dans le
processus de l'or en voie et la CEDEAO à
mon avis a décidé de donner encore une
chance à la médiation à aux bons office
en envoyant une délégation de haut
niveau qu'on sait composer du président
du Sénégal du Ghana et du Togo qui est
déjà médiateur à titre personnel puisque
le Togo s'est investi dans cela et le
Nigéria aussi et je pense que il y a en
tout cas une volonté d'arriver à un
dénouement par la négociation au-delà de
ça si le Mali ne cède pas comme
l'envisage de la Côte d'Ivoire il est
possible qu'il y ait des sanctions
prises par la Côte d'Ivoire mais aussi
par la Cedeao et ça je pense que le Mali
n'a pas besoin de ça puisque comme on
sait et le contenu de la feuille de
route que le Mali a proposé les
sanctions contre le Mali ont été élevé
il faut éviter je pense de revenir en
arrière alors peut-être rapidement vous
pouvez nous dire pourquoi est-ce que
l'agent guinéenne la gente malienne
pardon
garde en otage ou en tout cas objets de
Chantal c'est 46 soldats c'est soldats
ivoiriens je pense que à l'intérieur du
de la jointes il y a un courant qui est
plus porté vers la confrontation avec
ses voisins avec les Nations Unies mais
à partir du moment où par exemple un
pays comme le Nigéria a dépêché son
ministre beaucoup le président Macky
Sall qui est le président négatif de
l'Union africaine s'est rendu à partir
du moment où il y a eu beaucoup d'appels
à la compréhension à mon avis le Mali
gagnerait en tout cas à éviter une
nouvelle confrontation avec la CEDEAO
avec ses voisins parce que la
sous-région a besoin du Mali on ne peut
pas faire la lutte contre le terrorisme
ça le Mali et il faut que le Mali aussi
comprenne qu'il a besoin de la
sous-région parce que lui seul même en
faisant venir un partenaire extérieur ne
peut pas gagner la lutte contre les
groupes
absolument merci beaucoup c'est un sujet
que vous connaissez bien ces 10 Cabasse
donc je rappelle votre livre le Mali
Sahel notre Afghanistan à nous merci
beaucoup d'être passé dans ce journal de
l'Afrique merci à vous
on passe au reste de l'actualité en bref
et en images au Tchad l'évêque du Moyen
Charlie lance un appel à l'aide après
les affrontements entre
intercommunautaire qui ont fait une
dizaine de morts et une vingtaine de
blessés il y a quelques jours à Kiabi
dans le sud du pays de retour de
déplacements sur les lieux de des
affrontements le chef de l'Église
catholique dans cette province appelle
les autorités à porter assistance aux
victimes mais surtout à faire en sorte
que justice soit rendue
le président Centrafrique un persiste et
signe le référendum sur la nouvelle
Constitution soutiendra bien et ceci
même si la Cour constitutionnelle a
invalidé le décret qui menait à la
création de ce Comité chargé de rédiger
cette nouvelle Constitution un sujet qui
agite le pays 17 membres du bureau
exécutifs et des centaines de cadres du
parti de l'ancien président de Burkinabè
ont démissionné c'est une deuxième vague
de démission qui fait suite à un audit
qui a révélé dysfonctionnements au sein
du parti pour l'heure il n'est pas
question de création d'un nouveau parti
allez je vous emmène en Italie pour les
prochaines élections législatives de
dimanche à la rencontre d'un candidat
atypique il s'appelle Abubakar Soumaoro
il est Italo ivoirien ancien ramasseur
de tomates devenu représentant syndical
il est candidat de la gauche et se
présente comme le porte-parole des
exclus dans un pays où l'extrême droite
est au portes du pouvoir certains le
surnomme le Bernie Sanders italien
reportage de notre correspondante en
Italie Nathalie manoza
avec quelques dépliants à la main il
arpente les rues de Modène au nord de
l'Italie
c'est ici qu'à Boubacar Soumaoro lâche
mais en Côte d'Ivoire il est arrivé en
Italie à l'âge de 19 ans activiste à la
tête d'un syndicat de travailleur il est
devenu en quelques années le
porte-parole des ouvriers précaires une
cause qui a fait de lui l'une des
figures les plus connues de la gauche
italienne
il parle des problèmes réels des gens la
précarité l'exploitation ce sont les
préoccupations que nous les jeunes avons
en permanence car la situation n'est pas
facile
et il donne aussi une voix au
travailleur exploité qui travaille dans
les champs
un combat qu'il connaît bien car il a
lui-même été ramasseur de tomates dans
le champ du sud de l'Italie une
expérience qu'il a fait découvrir le
sort de milliers d'ouvriers agricoles
dans la péninsule j'ai récolté dans les
mêmes conditions de travail dur
qui commençait de l'Aube
jusqu'au soir coucher du soleil
12h 13h travail par jour pour installer
misérable vivant dans des conditions et
humaines j'ai dormi de la rue un passé
qui lui permet de comprendre
bien lui présenter une pétition avec une
liste de mesures en faveur de la
jeunesse
il a été le premier homme politique qui
a accepté de signer notre document il
est le premier à avoir pris le temps de
nous écouter d'entendre nos propositions
il ne s'agit pas d'idéologie mais de
questions concrètes
sa candidature est soutenue par la
gauche et les Verts c'est priorités la
mise en place d'un salaire minimum et la
lutte contre l'exploitation au travail
un programme avec lequel il espérait
réussir à faire barrage à l'extrême
droite en Italie
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
ceux qui nous ont suivis de Conakry
Abidjan en passant par New York restez
avec nous car l'actualité continue sur
France 24
[Musique]
RFI et France 24 présente
le Café des Sports votre émission 100%
football c'est tous les vendredis débat
passionnés échanges sans concession pour
une analyse complète de l'actualité
sportive de la semaine
[Musique]
le Café des Sports à vivre en direct sur
RFI et avoir sur France 24